morning everybody today is my 27th well  our 27th uh wedding anniversary and  we're gonna do our fit check we're  channeling old couple going to In and  Out and then sitting in the park because  we're cheap and we're bored and that's  what we do on our anniversary  all right  here's what I'm wearing show me your  outfit honey it's because I'm old  yeah look at that okay you did it all  right  good  have a very good day but today I'm  channeling uh from the movie Matilda  Miss Honey's a friend if they were doing  planting strawberries anyhow I'm left  unattended today my husband has gone to  Vegas to watch car races and therefore I  am left to my own devices which could  prove to be quite problematic because it  is also payday and I am bored so today  may be exciting I'm gonna let it lead me  where it will you too have a lovely day  and practice being unsupervised just go  wild  [Music]